the new Star Wars teasers straight from
d23 is finally out and the thing
everyone is talking about is dark ray so
in this quick video we're gonna dish out
everything we know about dark side ray
well I hate to burst your bubble but the
biggest theory out there is that this is
just a force vision similar to how Luke
saw himself as Vader while training on
Dagobah under Master Yoda but the
trailer here is really trying to get us
to believe that Rey will turn to the
dark side with Vader's breathing and
Emperor Palpatine voice over saying her
journey is finally coming to an end as
Luke says in the first teaser don't
worry Luke no one's ever really gone but
let's take a broader look at this theory
Star Wars has always been about good
versus evil from the clips we've seen so
far there is no other indication that
Rey is even remotely considering the
dark side she's either journeying with
Poe and Finn fighting kylo who I think
we can all agree is still a villain or
take a look at this image of her crying
with Leia it's gonna be a very difficult
sell to have her go from this to this
and have it be believable going back to
the initial teaser released in April we
get this image of the gang outside a
ruined Death Star it's entirely possible
that this Darkrai scene could take place
within these ruins along with her battle
with kylo speaking of kylo redditor jedi
paksas theorizes that this is a kylo Ren
vision given to him by a new character
called the Oracle who is described as an
alien parasite that sits on the head of
a giant sleeping baby adding to this
theory is the impact of Rian Johnson's
the last Jedi which caused major fan
backlash for its use of subverting
expectations with JJ Abrams back in the
helm it's very likely the franchise
won't be taking any major risks with its
characters rather it will follow the
traditional good-versus-evil approach
the original trilogy did
so having rey turned dark wouldn't fit
into the narrative considering she's
been built up as a good character for
the last two movies it would kind of be
like if Luke turned dark and returned to
the Jedi going back to JJ whose force
awakens was criticized for following the
same story structure of a new hole
the second theory is that Rey is
pretending to join the dark side much
like how Luke came to Vader in Return of
the Jedi donning his black sethe outfit
Rey pretending to go dark maybe what she
needs to do in order to gain access to
Palpatine or some other person or thing
finally we have the darkest timeline Rey
actually goes dark I previously
mentioned that having her go to the dark
side too quickly could result in some
problems kind of like how Daenerys going
to dark in Game of Thrones well let's
not get into that there's one key piece
of information about race past we still
need clarity on her real parents
jump treasures so do you want for
drinking money the final theory is a bit
of a doozy so hang tight in the Darth
Vader comic volume 25 we learned that
Palpatine was able to manipulate the
midi-chlorians inside Shmi Skywalker and
thus was able to make life within her
that would make Palpatine Anakin's
father a skill he likely learned from
Darth Plagueis who was obsessed with
immortality if Palpatine is somehow
raised father having manipulated a
woman's midi-chlorians it would
technically make her a brother to Vader
or at least a half-brother since me was
killed in attack of the clones but how
this revelation would turn her full
darkside is still yet to be known let's
not also forget that the original
beginning of the force awakens was
supposed to start with Luke's severed
hand floating in space gripping his
lightsaber but it was later cut from the
edit one theory is that this hand was
picked up and used to create clones of
the quote-unquote chosen one is there
any relation to that and to Rey then
there's some more info we can glean from
the images of Darkrai herself notice the
dual red sabers similar to those used by
the temple guards and the clone wars the
sabers themselves are very unstable
similar to that of kylo ren's suggesting
a cracked Kyber crystal we know in the
last Jedi Luke saber was cracked in half
so when rise of the Skywalker will
likely have Rey reconstructing this
crystal into a new dual blade this is
why we see her training earlier in the
trailer with the blue saber and a stick
likely because the other half hasn't
been constructed yet the theory goes
that kylo would see Rey with a red duel
saber but in reality she'll have a duel
bluesaver we also get a quick glance of
a ring on Ray's left hand leading some
to believe this is snoke's ring and she
could be under some sort of Sethe
possession meaning kylo might have to
save her by cutting off her hand just
like how Vader cut off Luke's hand of
course this is all speculation and with
the December release getting closer and
closer new theories will emerge I hope
you like this video make sure to LIKE
subscribe and comment and you can also
follow me on twitter at ding story YT
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much